[Music]
hey
you guys jenny says it seems like it's
moving real slow well
well just the intro video was i hope i
hope that we don't have any problems
because i don't know like we're in
central florida we're having really bad
thunderstorms
at the moment we haven't lost power or
anything like that but not yet
not yet but let me move over a little
bit and move on just a little bit i
don't know where to go
okay move them move them boobs over
there taking up all the room
well you know yeah i can't help but
massive sexy boobs
massive sexy moves [ __ ] right man you
trying to [ __ ] spotlight yourself and
take over the damn show
i i last time we were at the club i take
i was taking videos of jenny and
everything
while she was dancing and afterwards
when we were eating restaurants
and i made sure to get some good video
footage in there and [ __ ] got like
[ __ ] ton of likes and everything it's
like a friend of ours
wants to trade [ __ ] porn pictures and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] i don't you know who i'm talking
about oh
tony and my ex you're holding out on me
man you're holding
on i've already been with your
girlfriend and i
i introduced you to her like and after
we broke up
yeah she's so more juicy and you're not
gonna you're just trying to get pictures
of boobs
he's like yeah yeah he's because he's
gonna bust
he's not a bashing about that [ __ ] well
yeah yeah but i'm not
the thing is he's like we don't save him
and i'm like yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] he [ __ ] shares that with all
his other goth
[Laughter]
there's a porn underground you don't
know where you know it's you know you
don't know where that picture's going
yeah whole underground hot goth [ __ ]
girls and and their boyfriends [ __ ]
trading [ __ ] pictures and [ __ ]
and video clips well we can i'll tell
you they're all strippers anyway well
yeah yeah
they're just like whatever everyone has
already seen this [ __ ] right it's
because it's pretty old
but um but yeah so we'll talk a little
bit about uh the vampire ball because
like i said we did that friday but we'll
talk about let's talk about creep
shapers yeah okay
now uh okay so this was season two
episode two
which just uh dropped on thursday i
think they put up the new ones on
thursday
now uh yeah this was actually a decent
episode wasn't as cool as the first one
because i really really liked
how the first one had like a couple of
throwbacks you know what i mean this one
is a little bit more kind of one of the
middle-of-the-road ones like
entertaining but not super memorable
yeah i kind of forgot everything about
it well you know it's weird it's like i
was thinking about it this morning so
like like i said we watched it thursday
night when it came out
and then i was kind of like then today i
was like oh yeah we got to do the
matinee about the creep show and
you know the new creep show episode and
then i was like oh [ __ ] what
was in that yeah and then i remembered
the second one and then i was like what
was
the first one though and then i had to
like think about it and i was like oh
yeah yeah okay so you start talking
about it i'll remember
yeah like i said they're not bad they're
just not like super super
and i got confused too because i think
on one night we had put on
uh you know if you have shutter they
also have like a streaming thing
where you can just watch whatever they
put on and we had that on one night and
they were showing all the first
season creep shows so i watched i
rewatched a couple of those so maybe
that might have been why i
kind of forgot about it too because i
started sort of started watching some of
season one again
they're all good it's just it's like
it's a light watch they're not
you know it's like well that's my
entertainment yeah that's what they're
fun you don't really
have to you're not paying attention too
much yeah you can just kind of like
watch them while you're doing something
else it's just kind of fun it's like
every now and then you look up and
you're like oh that was [ __ ] that was
[ __ ] up you know what i mean so it's
that kind of thing yeah so this one uh
just like the last one had two stories
on it
the first one was called dead and
breakfast
and this was about a brother-sister team
one of whom was played by c thomas
howell and it's funny because i saw his
name
in the credits and then i was like
watching the thing and i was like
where's see thomas howell and then i'm
like oh my god
he's old as are we all well i didn't
expect him to like have gray hair and
everything else he doesn't look i mean
i just didn't recognize him at first i
know who that is he was uh he was real
big and he was in the hitcher
remember in 1986 with uh rucker howard
he was he's a younger guy i remember
that movie but i don't really remember
that we did we even reviewed that
yeah yeah he was the younger guy in that
okay so he was kind of like a big like a
you know
he was on the cover of like teen beat
and she looked at me
already said well tom doesn't remember
it then you know
yeah no we're not saying that well it's
not bad and the thing about it too is
that he doesn't pay as much attention to
them because he's usually i mean when
we're watching stuff i'm usually
watching it
and pay attention to it and he's usually
not paying attention
to it well sometimes i'm answering he's
usually on the tablet like with messages
you're watching something on youtube it
depends on what i'm never doing that if
it's something outstanding to know it
then i'm gonna you know
get all into it if it start i don't
explain my i don't explain myself to
anybody
maybe maybe you should no if it's
outstanding then i'll put everything
down and i'll be immersed into it
if it's just good or okay then i'm like
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah
i just kind of [ __ ] through it yeah
i'm having a good time but yeah but i'm
also doing tourism also
and i'm also not really all at caring
too much about it you know it's it's
that kind of stuff
but yeah if it's bad then i just totally
cut it out
like it didn't exist well like i said i
don't because i mean he
usually has he you know he has the
tablet but with me it's like i don't
i don't take my phone or the computers
or my laptops or anything like that into
the room so if i'm like concentrating on
something
it'll that's all i can concentrate on is
tv every now and then i'll sit and read
a book but other than that
in the first few minutes i get the
[ __ ] tone i know i know what kind of
well i know what i'm dealing with
usually
yeah they near it never surprises me i
know other tricks
yeah tom knows everything i know all
their tricks
yeah i see what's coming you know uh but
yeah so
so like i said this is these are both
very standard like creep show
mid-level creep show stories like i said
dead and breakfast is the first one it's
a brother and sister
and they have inherited this house from
their grandmother
now their grandmother was supposedly a
serial killer like
and uh it's very funny because the
sister their names are pam and sam
spinster which i think is very funny
uh but the grandmother was supposedly
like uh
one of the og serial killers and she
doesn't ever get talked about
which the sister pam is kind of pissed
off about she's like she should be super
famous you know she's
she's an influencer and she was like one
of the very early serial killers she was
an ax murderer
and uh so she knows all these stories
about this house so they're trying to
run it as a bed and breakfast but it's
not really
working out so uh you know because it's
just kind of flying under the radar
so they get the idea to invite this girl
who has kind of a horror true crimey
sort of youtube channel or whatever
um or you know whatever it is the kids
are doing these days
uh this kind of this kind of goth chick
named morg i think is her name
and they invite her there they say you
can stay here for free if you live
stream from here and you know
kind of hype up the place so we can get
more play
more people to stay so she does that but
then it turns out that a lot of the
stuff
that was legendary about this
grandmother of theirs and about these
murders and stuff
maybe not so much true or like a lot of
the legends about the house may be not
true
and so morg starts you know live
streaming to her followers it's like
this place is [ __ ] it's like you
know the brother and sister
runners are super desperate and it's
like they just want people to stay here
so they're making up all these stupid
ass stories
and so um at some point
the sister decides that she's going to
maybe make this into a murder house for
real
uh and you know where it's so like i
said it's it's a very standard creepshow
revenge
type of story so you know where it's
going to go but it's it was fun
it had um you know it was like real gory
kind of had a thing about
you know kind of a fun thing about how
how all these kind of bed and breakfasts
that are horror based
you know what i mean i don't think it
was criticizing that but it was just
kind of like lampooning that a little
bit
uh and how people are super into true
crime oh i want to stay in lizzie
borden's
death house and all this other kind of
crap so you know so that was like a real
enjoyable one but
like i said not super memorable but yeah
i don't remember that one yeah
but pretty decent overall then the
second one this one's a little weird
this one's called pesticide now this uh
this was directed by greg nicotero
and this had josh mcdermott who if
you're playing along at home
plays uh eugene on walking dead uh or
used to i don't know if he's still on
there did he die i don't even know
walking i'm gonna watch walking dead in
a few seasons i don't want to know if
he's still there or not
but he plays essentially john goodman's
character from arachnophobia so
you know what i mean except maybe like a
a scuzzy or more redneck version
uh but yeah so he's like a kind of a
real
um not very reputable uh what did they
call that exterminator
exterminator um so at the very beginning
he's at this doctor's office the doctor
is played by ashley lawrence from
hellraiser who looks pretty much
exactly the [ __ ] same as she looked
in 1987.
she must have had some work done she
looks great
i'm just saying because like i don't
know i was like because i saw her name
and i was just like oh man the hell
raised her chick and then i was like i
wonder how she's gonna look these days
she looks pretty much exactly the same
yeah some people don't age that much
it's crazy
yeah she's not in it a lot but she's
sort of just like in the
in the beginning in the end so uh so i
guess she's kind of like [ __ ] to him
but deservedly so because he's kind of
uh a [ __ ] so he's like i'm gonna
dump a bunch of roaches in her [ __ ]
place and then she's gonna have to call
me and come back
so but then he gets invited to this very
strange
job which is like at this derelict
property
and uh this dude named murdock
played by the fantastic keith david
yeah is uh good job in this one he's man
he's good at everything
yeah anything that has keith david in it
it's just like yeah it rocks
keith david or his voice yeah one or the
other right
um he was kind of like the second part
of uh of uh old west's name
did darth vader uh [ __ ] james yeah james
old zone he's like the second james earl
jones
but he has his own thing going he has a
great voice he does yeah
so so keith david's character murdoch
invites this this exterminator there and
he's basically like well i
i want to you know turn this property
into condos i have a whole bunch of
these derelict properties
but i have a little bit of a vermin
problem now you can see where this is
going the vermin that he wants them to
wipe out are
homeless people so
even though um josh mcdermott's
character i want to call him eugene but
i guess he's named
king uh in the like mr king or something
like that
in the in the thing he even though he's
kind of like
a [ __ ] he was just he kind of box it
he's like man i don't really want to do
that even though but keith dave is like
but look all this money and he's just
like oh well maybe maybe
but then when it comes time to do it
he's just kind of like conflicted
and uh it so happens that all of the
homeless people do end up dead sort of
not accidentally on purpose and from
then point from that point on
it goes into this weird i guess that
the exterminator's guilt is like [ __ ]
with him so now he's seeing like all
these giant bugs
everywhere um which are really well done
i don't know i don't think they're cgi i
think they're
they were models and they were stop
motion i mean they look like they were
really
there yeah the the giant bugs in this
are actually really what's funny is it
kind of felt kind of some call backs in
terms
to the movie the thing that keith david
was in yeah you know what i mean like
special effects kind of reminded me of
the thing
they did a bit yeah it's pretty good and
i want to say this was a little bit of a
call back to
from the first creep show the movie from
1982 the final segment they're creeping
up on you with like the guy with the
with the roaches um so it's a little bit
like that and actually even when they
show
because you know if you watch the show
they show like the creep show comic book
like at the end
and when they had the artwork for this
particular story on there even said
they're creeping up on you on it so they
were
very you know very obviously making
reference to that
um and then there's 1.2 where he i feel
like he gets like shrunk down and like
squooshed and
all this other kind of stuff it's it's
crazy yeah it's weird um but yeah it's
it's a little i don't know i felt like
the story was a little muddled
but i did like a lot of the gore in it i
really liked all the giant bug
effects looked really good they were
just having fun they were yeah
and i plus i couldn't figure out who
keith david's character was he supposed
to be the devil
i don't know i thought he was just
supposed to be like a gangster
yeah but i don't know i kind of felt
like he did maybe he was a
representation of satan i thought he was
supposed to be the devil
all right because you know like lord of
the flies type thing i didn't really
read too much into it i was just
watching it well somebody like called
him the devil or made it made some kind
of reference to him is that so i thought
like he was
literally supposed to be the devil
because he was like tempting
the exterminator yeah hey i'll give you
all this money if you kill all these
innocent people
yeah you know what i mean yeah i wasn't
analyzing it it was good though
you know what i mean yeah you're not i
wasn't paying that close attention i was
yeah you had a big i was really
trying well like i said i'm a writer i'm
a storyteller so i'm interested in other
people's stories and i'm just like okay
well what is it what is what does that
mean well it wasn't
very long it wasn't very long i mean it
was shorter than twilight zone episode
yeah well yeah 11 minutes no no no no
it's longer than that because the the
whole episode is
i think they're both they're all about
45 minutes so and there's two stories so
each story is like 20
minutes like 22 23 minutes something
like that so so basically like sitcom
length yeah
yeah i don't know like i feel like i
don't i don't know
both of the stories were were good maybe
the maybe the second one was slightly
better but just because of
keith david being in it which like i
said that's always a plus and i like the
bug stuff
but i don't know they're both they're
the stories were so different that i
don't know if you can really like
compare them
but that was one thing that i liked
about season one of creep show too is
that they
they really seem to try to get different
types of stories going like per episode
you know what i mean
yeah um i'd have to see it again yeah i
mean we should probably if we had time
we should probably watch this week
but we have so much [ __ ] we gotta look
at that's what i mean and like i said
ever since i started doing you know the
extra two movie reviews a week it's like
now i've been watching like a lot of
[ __ ]
like other movies that you're not even
watching i still gotta stack that tall
of dvds that bird
and blu-rays that people sent us yeah to
react to
i know we really didn't get it and then
half of them were sophie
that was so soapy yeah it's bad i know i
feel really bad because we have like so
many
and like i said i have a huge list of
movies that people are recommending
and movies that i've been wanting to do
for a really long time it just takes
such
such a long time to sit down and watch
them research them
record the [ __ ] you know what i mean and
then do everything else because yeah you
gotta worry about shirts
yeah that's coming soon i saw them show
you that design yeah but
yeah i i got a couple messages from
people that wanted uh that one of them
that sent me their addresses and stuff
so uh so yeah like i said if you're in a
creep show just go check it out it's not
as good as the first one
the first uh you know episode but it was
still like a pretty solid
middle of the road type episode um
you want to talk a little bit about the
vampire ball like i said everybody
everybody that was here friday night
knows that we left yeah well we didn't
leave but we did a whole show but then
after the show was over
we went to roots of there we posted some
pictures yeah we went to the vampire
volcano
i have to say i was astounded
by the turnout that they had yeah i was
expecting it to be
sort of like i don't know i was
expecting like a lot of people to come
but i thought most people
wouldn't bother showing up i thought it
would be kind of like but it was like
crowded and i was like 95
of the people like dressed up like big
time like yeah
it was a big deal like
it's it's interesting because you get
that's downtown sanford
and downtown sanford there's a lot of
kind of
you know normal people bars i guess
there's a lot of like sports bars and
that kind of stuff
so you always get those kind of people
like wandering in there um
and hanging out in there because they
don't do because he does other types of
nights like other
days so a lot of bikers too yeah that as
well
you got bikers hanging out bikers
rednecks and i guess you could just call
them like you know
yuppies what is that what you'd call
them yeah i guess i don't know what
they're calling them nowadays
just people people they all look alike
to us yes
people people yeah they all look like to
us they all dress the same you with your
khakis but
yeah you know we probably all look like
we dress the same of them too so
i don't know that's yeah that's true
what i have noticed though is that
i guess because it's not in downtown
orlando
um they don't seem to give a [ __ ] as
much
you know what i mean there hasn't been
any trouble
well not since not when we've been there
i don't know if there's been i don't
think there has been
i think they know what it is and there's
a bunch of bars along that stretch so i
feel like it's not
i mean you know it's usually people kind
of just making around
bars like in the because downtown
stanford is very very small it's only
like a couple of blocks
yeah you know because i think they know
i think because i remember [ __ ] there
once
like dimitri put on some what was it
it was joy division and they started
dancing to that they knew what that was
yeah although it wasn't the original
version no it was some reason
like it was a cover yeah they put they
put that on and then uh
see i i don't think it i don't think i
don't think they're as shocked by it as
they were
definitely back in the 90s in the very
early 2000s yeah that was a big
difference
yeah big difference nowadays yeah but
yeah it was a really fun night everybody
had really really cool
outfits on and pretty big headpieces
everybody did a lot of people did kind
of like victorian looking
like big dresses and masks and blood and
all that kind of stuff so it was like
pretty cool they had a contest we missed
the first part of it because we were out
on the backpack yeah
but um i think i got some pictures yeah
you probably do
and uh we went to chantal's after yeah
and uh i got a video of that yeah
man it's a i guess it was like really
they had a lot of takeout orders that
night because it took forever
to get the food because they were really
really behind
because like i said i think that's the
only restaurant in downtown samford
that's open
all night so people that are out
clubbing and you want to get something
to eat that's pretty much the only game
in town
so they get really really backed up no
karaoke
sadly they had the thing and i thought i
saw the two guys over there that had
been to
karaoke the other night and i was like
oh boy more karaoke but they didn't
i got something different this time i
think i got fried shrimp and fries but
like i said it took forever
and by the time i got there it's like i
ate the shrimp and like that my fries
were running late because they
you know had to cook them and then by
the time the fries got there i wasn't
hungry anymore so i just took up opening
them later
but yeah it was like a really really
slow you got you got some pictures
that's you can't i can't see that okay
that was the very beginning yeah that
was very early in the night yeah that
was very early
jenny
[Laughter]
yeah amanda said did anyone ask you to
be a donor that happened to me at the
vampire bar in new orleans
no no we did well like i said most of
the people that
were at this one we know all of them so
it's not like
and i this mostly seemed like less
serious because we've been to we went to
the vampire ball in tampa which is kind
of like that endless night
you know the same one that they did a
long time ago that was a long time ago
and i kind of feel like that that's more
people that are
actually into blood play and all that
kind of stuff whereas this one just
seemed like
oh let's dress up and this is the gup
night yeah it was just a goth night and
everybody's just like well it's a goth
night but we get to dress up more than
we normally would
you know what i mean so it was that kind
of thing so and like i said we know
pretty much everybody at the place at
least
through a couple of you know jenny
chantal oh that's at chantal's yeah
look i'm sticking that [ __ ] in my face
and then
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yeah yep chantel
well we were going over there because we
cuz everybody was out front like smoking
and stuff and then i was kind of like
we're gonna get out of chantal's and i
think it was angel and she said
man their chicken and waffles was really
good and i was like oh
chicken and waffles but then when i got
there i kind of wanted chicken and
waffles but then i thought it'd be like
too much for me to eat
and then jen told me to their carrot
cake was amazing and i'm just kind of
like
i love carrot cake but i was like i know
i'm not going to be able to eat that
so she said yeah it's a big huge feeling
with these two
oh yeah we ended up saying what that
them
in the little window seat because they
kind of came in and said come and sit
inside with us
look at my face look at my face
[Laughter]
my big pointy nose yeah they were making
out and stuff well you know everyone
everyone was pretty uh hammered and that
was like a two in the morning i think
they're all like in their early 20s and
[ __ ] yeah we're hanging out with the
youngsters
[Laughter]
yeah i think she was only 25. he might
have he seemed a little bit older
i don't remember what his name was i'd
seen him around but i didn't know what
his name was
jenny definitely looks suspicious
[Laughter]
yeah well you know yeah it was fun
though
uh next up memento mori yeah but that's
a week from tomorrow that's on monday
all right uh you seem like you're eager
to yeah i don't have anything to say i'm
kind of sleepy
yeah i know me too yeah
all right so we will be back tomorrow do
you want to do another we'll probably do
um uh and on the menu tomorrow like a
food show
okay so be thinking about something i
already got i already got it are you
already got an idea
yeah you're going to tell me what it is
or is it going to be a surprise
i want to talk about what could be done
with like shelf stable stuff
like powdered milk powder that's a good
idea [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] that you can stockpile for
emergencies like [ __ ] hurricanes and
disasters
crap like that what you can do with it
that's actually a great idea things like
powdered butter
how to use all that because we've done
that too like sometimes when we have
because we have like a bunch of canned
[ __ ]
and then sometimes you know when it's a
year or two old and you want to rotate
some [ __ ] out you're like well
use your mouth you gotta you gotta use
this [ __ ] up and you know
so you gotta have them i'm gonna show
you guys some [ __ ] real powdered milk
the good powdered milk and what to do
with it
and what what you can make out of it and
then how to use it in an emergency
situation
okay yeah yeah so we'll do
yeah amanda smith said you have to do
curry we we eventually will
okay we will we won't do a whole cur
we'll either do a curry show or just do
an indian food in general although
indian food is such a broad topic maybe
we should just do it specifically it's a
[ __ ] huge topic we could do curry on
uh a tuesday if you want yeah we could
do that
most indian food is a [ __ ] variation
of curry it's all kind of curry that's
true so maybe we can do they just call
it different things but really if you
analyze what they're doing
in these uh fast food or more of these
you know sit down indian restaurants
it's all a variation of the same thing
that's true yeah
all right so we will be back tomorrow at
3 p.m eastern standard time talking
about some food
thanks everybody for dropping by have a
good rest of your weekend
and we'll see you guys tomorrow bye